a
[Música]
d
siete de la tarde 26 de junio invierno
años atrás sentado en una fría butaca
blanca
con personas alrededor en silencio
mirando un punto fijo en el piso o la
pared también blanca
de repente se abre una puerta vaivén y
se escucha comienza el horario de visita
ahora usamos miradas entre familiares me
levanto y lentamente ingreso a la sala
de terapia intensiva
ahí estaba jorge mi abuelo
con su infaltable radio en la mesita de
luz junto unos bombones que había pedido
como todas las semanas lleváramos para
el personal que lo atendía
y van varios días en que el habitaba esa
cama ya casi no podía expresarse estaba
con oxígeno y todo el cablerío conectado
a su cuerpo así todo era tan inteligente
y bondadoso que logró dejarnos un
mensaje verbalmente a cada uno de sus
nietos
después de estar tomados de la mano unos
minutos se escuchó martín todo es
cuestión de perspectiva
en ese momento yo estaba en plena
búsqueda bueno como siempre pero no
podía responderme ninguna de las
preguntas que me hacía como para
orientar un poco el sentido de esta
exploración había dejado atrás estudios
universitarios que no se me dejaban en
nada lo que sentía y había comenzado
enfermería y clown payaso así todo no
estaba al ciento por ciento convencido
convencido de lo que estaba haciendo en
realidad sí pero quería hacer muchas
otras cosas carpintería jardinería
sociología psicología y
pero ese mensaje esa última palabra fue
el impulso que estaba necesitando un
abrazo lleno de seguridad de que me
decía es por acá
ese día me fui a mi casa repitiendo
perspectiva perspectiva perspectiva
la figura del payaso existen diferentes
civilizaciones a lo largo de la historia
a menudo esto eran los únicos que podían
expresarse contra las normas sociales
establecidas los lakota un pueblo
indígena ubicado en lo que ahora es eeuu
los llamaron choca estos eran los
contrarios los al revés se decía que
estaban inspirados por fuerzas
espirituales y por lo tanto tenía una
vocación sagrada
estos payasos sagrados eran los únicos
que llegaban a conocerse a sí mismo
porque iban en busca de sus debilidades
más esenciales y se asumían en todas sus
contradicciones
por eso cada vez que había un nuevo
payaso payasa debe empezar a hacerlo
todo al revés hablar en palíndromo de
atrás hacia adelante cabalgar mirando la
cola del caballo caminar de espaldas
la inversión del mundo la inversión de
la normalidad el darle vuelta a las
cosas y lo que nos permite ver más allá
de lo que nos está permitido ver a
simple vista
era eso lo que me dijo mi abuelo no
perspectiva
es investigar este término la palabra
perspectiva deriva de pérez píxeles
compuesto por el prefijo ver qué
significa a través de ello completamente
y especie que significa mirar observar
lo que sería observar completamente oa
través de algo
y con esto no quiero introducirme en un
campo científico
al contrario recuerdo que en la
universidad permanentemente me querían
inculcar estos conocimientos
verificables pero una de las mayores
enseñanzas que tuvo en esos años me la
dejó una profesora que nos dijo a un
grupo de alumnas y alumnos al entrar en
una habitación
no miren observen
fue lo más humano que aprendí en esos
años porque claro lo que ella nos quería
decir era que no utilicemos simplemente
el sentido de la vista sino que estemos
perceptivos
y justamente es lo que vengo trabajando
todos estos últimos años y lo que
intento hacer al ingresar como payaso en
una habitación de un hospital observar
percibir para poder lograr un encuentro
estando en ecuador con un grupo de
payasos y payasos de distintos países en
un hospital geriátrico ingresamos por un
pasillo me paro en una habitación y de
allí observó
adentro había cuatro mujeres recortadas
cuáles tres de ellas estaban en compañía
de algún amigo o amiga familiar personal
de salud o quien fuere
y una de ellas estaba sola era rosa
me llamó mucho la atención porque nadie
interactuaba entonces me acerco en su
dirección y me doy cuenta de que no veía
cuando me acerco aún más para hablarle
la señora de la cama al lado me dice
equipo acústica no te va a escuchar
en ese momento me pregunte que podría
hacer a través del arte del payaso en
una situación como ésta
estando en un país con costumbres
distintas a las nuestras y frente a una
persona con la cual no podía comunicarme
ni visual ni verbalmente
algo pasó
fueron unos segundos de silencio que
hicieron que dejara de pensar y empezar
a escuchar a ese sabio al que tanta
falta nos hace conocer
el cuerpo
entonces me siento a su lado nos tomamos
de la mano y empezamos a jugar ya ver
que nos generaba el choque la caricia el
contacto el sentirnos y reconocernos
fueron largos minutos de juego
hasta que me pasa a buscar una compañera
porque nos teníamos que retirar y al
despedirnos rosa me dice
ármate una cama a mi lado hoy
verdaderamente nunca voy a saber qué
sintió o si hay algo en ella cambio en
esos minutos pero lo que sí puede
imaginar que quizás desde ese momento en
adelante las demás personas de la
habitación se acerquen a jugar con las
manos y quizás rosa se ponga feliz al
saber que aún en un ambiente tan hostil
y entre tantos desconocidos siempre va a
haber alguien que intente ver más allá
de sus limitaciones
para generar un encuentro
lo que también sé es lo que me género
este segundo mensaje que me trae un
momento tan simple como entrelazar los
dedos al borde de una cama
rosa me estaba enseñando la importancia
del silencio
y que si yo me dejaba llevar por mi
intuición y mi ingenuidad sacando todas
las caretas y etiquetas que traía ella
permitía quemarme una cama a su lado y
así quizás encontrarnos soñando juntos
para poder atesorar ese instante
me estaba enseñando que cuidar a una
persona es observar a través de ella
estar en modo percepción con todos los
sentidos aguzados como para lograr ser
el carpintero de un sueño
para curar hay que conocer la enfermedad
pero para cuidar hay que conocer a la
persona porque no somos la ciega
hipoacúsica de la cama 9
somos una persona íntegra somos holismo
somos rosa
entonces ante un sistema médico
hegemónico que en vez de cuidar invita a
curar
vienen por los pasillos blancos y fríos
del hospital payasos y payasos que a
través del juego y la comicidad intentan
que ese paciente en vez de padecer y
tener un rol pasivo en su proceso de
salud esté activo trabajando en ese
encuentro la perspectiva
me canto y me celebro me celebro y me
canto y si me encantó y me celebró te
celebró y te canto porque cada átomo que
me pertenece te pertenece porque cada
tomo que te pertenece me pertenece
porque tú y yo somos la misma cosa
gracias
[Música]